the most dangerous game on the planet
cinnamon toast cool
did you read me I think I hear you no I
don't know it so it's so dark it's not
go play in the darkest most evil game
ever conceived and that darkest most
evil game ever conceived what is it what
do we call this game by the way the most
dangerous game the most dangerous game
over a game of rock paper sis on the
winner will get to control the other
person's computer for 30 seconds
remotely no it's too much it's too much
30 seconds
Oh 30 thing it is nothing shut up don't
be noisy nope don't puss out on me now
can you sign the contract
okay okay I'm complicated to play this
game I'll slap yourself Wow hurts I'm
ready too Oh
I don't hear you slapping yourself oh
yeah what I do it again harder oh yeah
[Music]
are you ready ken you ready oh god I
suck at this with you you're in my head
I hate it every time I already know what
you gonna pick a thousand years before
you pick it shut the [ __ ] up Ken
mmm god damn it
does that mean I [ __ ] your [ __ ] up [ __ ]
okay I'm hacking into your computer game
oh my god all these warning hacks
Ken's computer hacking co-sister [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god
I need more time Oh what is that
this is wait a minute this is not what
you think it is I'm a huge fan
what the [ __ ] can what the [ __ ] is this
wait a minute you play wow what are you
[ __ ] nerd yo you are you are you
downloaded water what no don't make me a
nerd
please don't download one crap No oh
Jesus Christ what are you gonna do in
there not the beta beta
that's rap Mitch I roll the hard damn
let's give me 30 seconds get the [ __ ]
outta damn it ah [ __ ] I don't know if I
can uncie just like my desktop the [ __ ]
was that ken you got a problem with it
no I don't all right get ready for
another round of another round of
Rochambeau you think you're smarter than
me you think you're better than me
god damn it all right I'm hacking into
your computer can't take much more this
please stop
too much hacking oh god he's in no oh no
not not Vince at sex please anything but
that oh no gasps numbers oh no panic
pathetic numbers no not my head vlogplus
please don't touch the head wait wait a
minute what what what what the [ __ ] is
this Ken what do you mean it's his
adblock uh yeah no no turn up don't
pause my head [ __ ] no no don't baby
watch youtube videos oh oh god wait oh
wait a minute what you're not subscribed
err you not subscribe you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like all the [ __ ] videos
this is how a should have already been
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] can i [ __ ]
dare you
ah 30 seconds to [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] god
dammit I didn't even get started
god damn Oh guys still playing pity Papa
Diaz I can't believe you're not
subscribed to me you [ __ ] [ __ ] how
long have we been friends you know that
no no I'm at a friendship kid could ever
make me want us be subscribe to your
channel you next round should you win
this one maybe I'll pick Rock okay
alright next Ram cinema to see you're
going down I think we're not gonna be
friends after this well it's gonna be
worth it anyway we never we're friends
get out of here [ __ ] I'm Hawking
your computer you can never trust me
again [ __ ] no wait 30 seconds I got
some stuff prepared for you my dogs not
my dogs
it's my dog's gonna do to you why would
you make that can we save this image
oh my god this is this is what this is
this this is the Utah this is the real
YouTube behind-the-scenes you've seen it
here that's a nice tattoo man thanks man
thanks brother
oh my god this is the the hottest thing
I've ever seen in my life
no wait no no you're not supposed to
like it oh my god oh good okay Kent for
[ __ ] sake
no stop sharing stop sharing oh thank
you
are you done yet [ __ ] face god damn it's
like three to nothing
three to nothing bit decided okay well
I'll pick rock for sure this will you I
promise I'm picking rock okay I believe
you
[Music]
now you did reverse psychology it didn't
work yes come on Kane what are you going
do what are you gonna do what do you do
come on can what are you gonna do oh
baby no no no no I'm gonna pay you back
for all this pain to give me downloaded
the beta for water Warcraft made my back
real markiplier sucking your dick get
out of here can not with it what is this
what is this now anything to check
septic a video anything but you hack
detective
speaker phone stops ringing well it gets
worse it gets worse oh do you see you
soon we're right there you go please I
can't stand any mouth we're gonna
support ah yes now we're gonna send him
a euro wait Spreadshirt no shirt again
has it been 30 seconds yet [ __ ] you son
of a bell I bet my mind I bet my
information it's not saved well I bet my
paypal is insane buy it now you would
add a [ __ ]
what No
the 48 or 49 Tobuscus shirts kill him
with your awesome man they were below
sea of orcas goddammit I subscribed all
these channels less it's a [ __ ] in a
way all right fine
another round alright another round it
is
you'll never suspect what I'll pick yes
Oh baby not again
don't hang in a Kent you can't
thumbnails down another look at my stop
[Music]
no not my Twitter seriously you can't do
[Applause]
[Music]
angry oh no can't leave II know it's not
funny Kent
yeah come on Twitter Swift alright
anyway if you get nudes I'm gonna be
pissed okay
alright we're doing one more round
mother [ __ ] one more round you don't
know me baby no oh you know got him in
your mainframe [ __ ] handle it no not my
computer Jesus Christ I hear the house
there's no bother surging through your
veins [ __ ] let's get it let's get it
all my wins going oh no no what are you
doing oh geez what are you doing man
what are you doing Oh manna [ __ ] no oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] I thought it would ask first
Jesus Christ Kent Kent Oh anyway guys
thanks for playing the world's most
dangerous game I really didn't mean to
actually kill his computer he's gonna be
pretty pissed all right well that was
the most dangerous game on the planet
check out another part that we did right
here and check out cams channel drop
down there right right in my crotch
that's right and I'll see you guys in
the next video hopefully that deleted
kiss channel to kiss [ __ ] that [ __ ]